there's a lot of skepticism right now
about what putin's going to do what
putin's not going to do as a former kgb
member yourself
in situations like this
right like you know yuri talks about
demoralization destabilization
you know crisis
normalization these phases you go
through and he even takes a deeper
propaganda disinformation deception
sabotage subversion espionage all these
things that he talks about
and that's the playbook of kgb let's
just say if it is the playbook of kgb
if you could
think
to the best your abilities on what the
kgb was trained to do the true believers
and you've heard putin say there's no
such thing as a former kgb you've heard
them say that before like there's such
as a former country
what do you think his next moves are
what do you think he does in a situation
like this because in the world right now
he's seen like the next hitler
i
don't want to really disappoint you but
that kgb training
um that he brags about
wasn't that good for him he wasn't he
was not he was not a well-trained agent
he uh he's a masterful politician
and clearly you know
he
everybody in the kgb was familiar with
but that kind of stuff but but that
doesn't mean that they weren't doing it
very well
yes active measures
was uh particularly under andropov
andropov actually issued uh uh
a rule that every active kgb agent must
be involved in some way doing active
measures so he was very much uh for it
and and there were a number of successes
that they had but it was not on a large
scale and i think i told you it's the
last time that you know to uh they
managed to
uh put to put this the big lie out there
that uh j edgar hoover was a secret
cross-dresser
and you're saying that was not true it
was not true it was not true uh there
there's a the
um
vlasili mutrokin was a kgb archivist and
he smuggled a lot of material out
of of the archives
and uh in his book there's a section
about our active measures and there's a
number of things where they
uh where he says yeah the kgb didn't did
this that for instance the uh kennedy
assassination all the rumors that were
floating around they were initiated by
the kgb and sort of uh placed
into western media a friendly western
media sort of left-wingish and then
picked up by the new york times and so
forth uh that was successful but this
massive undermining of western society
there there's no no such word uh
in in mitrogan's book uh he actually
says that the the the department that
was responsible for active measures was
the least desirable you know the agents
the good ones all wanted to live in the
west
surprise surprise
and so they had a lot of failures but
they succeeded uh in particular
specific situations and
uh
disinformation you know this is uh you
don't have to be a trained agent that's
uh
almost all governments do it don't we
you know we have an agenda we
uh
we we have a narrative and uh we only
talk about the stuff that fits our
narrative right
we do it too
on the left and on the right
uh so and as i as i said i think putin
is uh
probably the the smartest politician in
the last 100 years uh i mean really
think about it he may he may maintain
power for 20-plus years
in a country where the standard of
living has not really improved
he
that means
he he's a
phenomenal manipulator of his own people
all right they
they're buying into the the uh you know
the tale that that's that's one of the
major narratives that that
russia is constantly under threat from
from the west and by uh you know having
ex-warsaw pact countries joined nato
we
gave him some ammunition i'm not saying
we shouldn't have let them into nato but
but there's some reality to it and uh
as uh people who follow history know
that
russia has historically always been
under attack since its foundation from
everywhere
and so
in in the in the russian
national
genetic makeup
there is a desire for a strong person a
strong leader
you know this is succession there were
some of the czars then we had lenin we
had stalin
and now it's putin
because they're afraid of yet another
invasion
that fear
in my view is
unjustified but you know how do you how
do you get this out of you know the uh
the most primitive part of your brain
fear
now jack do you consider yourself
german russian american all of above
just american now where do you classify
yourself right now so
there's one one uh
answer i give to this uh today i'm
legally
intellectually and emotionally an
american
period with german roots but i wouldn't
even use the hyphenation because
um there's a difference between me and
my my wife she's also
has american citizenship
but uh that she was she's originally
from jamaica when she says we
she means to make her when i say we i
mean the united states and us and them
mr germans can you even go back to
germany
i have
russia no you cannot go to russia no not
even close no germany yes though germany
i've traveled in in western europe
in several countries i also was in
poland
uh russia no you see
when when you
show up there
accidents can easily be arranged and
where russia yeah it's it's it's very
very difficult don't drink what they
give you yeah it's very difficult to
arrange an assassination
on foreign uh in a foreign land it's
very difficult and they don't have that
many teams that can do that
but once you show up in moscow
and and you know putin is a master in
sending messages to the world why did he
go after scrape paul
this this was uh you know the the fellow
that uh uh was poisoned in london
he was already exchanged that's the end
normally in the espionage world uh he
was in jail and he was then exchanged by
the by the brits for
uh some folks that they were holding
uh that that is the end of the game
and he's so fit to just send the message
you know what
we
we can get we can go after you no matter
what so that's why one
why would i anyway go back to moscow
i've been to saint petersburg and
moscow and there isn't much else to be
seen and and i think i think he wants to
go and he wants to go with you because i
think adam likes the russian ladies over
there there's
sunny isles florida so if you enjoyed
this little segment from the podcast
click over here to watch the entire
podcast and if you've not subscribed to
the channel please do so take care
everybody
[Music]